la pasteure de décor à cette fiction
assure ici de boccace qu'il a écrit
quelques années après le très peu
d'années après le la patinoire 10e en 13
150 à 350 2 et se sont en effet cette
jeune fille ce dernier que cette jeune
fille et trois garçons qui quittent
florence où sévit la poste pour se
dépasser et extra muros en un lieu où
chacun quotidiennement à tour de rôle
raconte une histoire dont le thème est
choisi par un roi ou une reine fictive
et là on voit effectivement que la
littérature est un puissant direct à un
puissant dérivatif à 7 cette mélancolie
et a7 à cet effroi ses peurs qui qui
sévissent à cette époque là il y a
également pétrarque qui dans son ouvrage
sur la vie solitaire recommande eux de
quitter la ville et ses ennuis ces
problèmes et de se retrouver à la
campagne pour se ressourcer c'est
également aussi pour le bien de certains
intellectuels qui partent à la campagne
il ya effectivement quelque chose d'un
peu contemporain enfin dans suite dans
cette évocation là dans cette espèce de
fuite de déplacement mais avec
naturellement des effets qui sont
majeurs puisque on discrimine le virus
on se déplace
[Musique]